MALE SPEAKER: A little
bit of background
about Carol and why someone from
the food team is hosting her.
So Carol's initial book,
"The Responsible Business",
came out a little while back.
And we adopted it
into the framework
within our global
food program strategy.
And we've been using her
book and the strategy
behind that for
the last two years.
And so I'm sure Carol will have
some juicy tidbits to share
about that.
So it's super exciting to have
her back here in sunny Mountain
View.
"The Responsible
Business" framework
really identifies five
windows through which
businesses view
their activities.
And this is something
that she'll speak to,
but it's really interesting
to kind of get it out
there now to start
thinking about it.
The five areas or
the five activities
are the customers
that you think about,
the co-creators, which
she'll talk through,
the Earth, around being
sustainable-- something
the Google is all about-- the
community in which we work
and live, and then the last one
via the investors, making sure
we're making money
and being profitable.
So Carol has collaborated with
Fortune 100 and entrepreneur
CEOs for four decades in
building "The Responsible
Business"-- that is a
re-imagined idea of success
and how to get there with the
benefit to all stakeholders.
Carol authored a
multi-award-winning book
by the same name, which
tells those stories.
The new book, "The Responsible
Entrepreneur"-- in front of me,
here-- just came on
July 7, this fall.
She is the founder and faculty
at the Responsible Entrepreneur
Institute, intermittent lecturer
at MIT Sloan, Harvard Business,
Michigan Ross, Toronto
Rotman, and the University
of [INAUDIBLE] for Innovation
and Entrepreneurship.
She also blogs for
CNBC, Stanford Social,
Innovation Review,
and many others.
Carol plays with
making and sharing food
and thinking about
the business of food
and its place in communities
and where she lives.
It is my pleasure to introduce
Carol Sanford, a member
of our Food Innovation Lab
and author of her latest
book, "The Responsible
Entrepreneur".
So with that, I give you Carol.
CAROL SANFORD: Thank you.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you.
CAROL SANFORD:
Thank you very much.
Thank you all for coming.
I thought I would start
with a bit of a story
and see if you can
relate to the story.
When I was very
young-- I can actually
remember, as early as four years
old-- having a thought about,
I wonder how much I
could do with my life.
Now, I didn't have
those words for it,
but I remember feeling like
that there was something
if you set out to do it, you
could make a big difference.
Now, at that point,
I have to tell you,
what I was thinking about was
rescuing the dogs that the dog
catcher picked up.
But as time went on, by the time
I was six or seven years old,
I lived-- well, I
had made a decision
about the time I was
six or seven years old
that a lot of my work should
be about reversing racism.
And part of that was
because I grew up
in the panhandle of Texas,
where it was rampant.
And it was rampant in my family.
So there are various paths
I've followed through my life
to try and do what
I can with my life.
And I have, in that process,
become absolutely fascinated
with cultures that make
it possible for people
to make a really big
difference with their life,
and for people who managed to
rise to unbelievable challenge
and accomplish great
things, even when
they don't have a culture
that supports them.
How many of you felt
like when you were young
that you might want to do
something big with your life?
Did anybody-- you
had that thought.
Yeah.
So I find in many
cultures, you don't
have all the words for it,
but it's sort of there.
I also-- having been here
hanging out with Googlers
for a couple of years now
through the Food Experience
Innovation Lab with Scott
and [? Michel ?] [? Bacher ?]
and, what, 100 other folks--
have come to realize what
a culture this is for people
being able to actually realize
and do something
amazing with their life.
But the question I have for
you today and what this book is
about, this new book, is are you
fully taking advantage of it?
And so today, instead
of me just lecturing
to you, which I
find really boring,
I'm going to offer
you some stories.
And I'm going to
start with asking
a question I'd like for you to
use to think as we go along.
And instead of you asking
me questions, like a Q&A,
I'm going to ask you questions.
And I'm going to stop
and ask you to comment.
Is that fair?
And if you absolutely say-- I'll
probably call on you anyway,
but you can try that.
Because it's much more fun
if we engage rather than just
me telling you what I think.
Because I don't think I'm
any bigger expert than you
are at this, I've just
lived it a little longer
and met a lot more people,
potentially, than you have.
So I want to start
with this question.
If you were to think
about the evolution
of a healthier society,
a healthier ecosystem,
and you were to say,
personally-- not
what Google says, not what
my unit or my work is about,
but, me personally.
Where do I think
is the biggest--
and using Google language--
10x place to leverage?
If I were just going
to take on something
and I were really going
to drive something
I thought would create a
much healthier ecosystem
and a healthier society,
what would I pick?
What would I say is like the
node or the point to intervene,
that if I were going
to put my life energy
and I were going to
make a big difference,
that might be where
I would put it.
Do you have thoughts
about the answer to that?
Anybody have a thought
AUDIENCE: People.
CAROL SANFORD: Where?
CAROL SANFORD: People.
And any specific thing
you'd do with people?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: Yeah.
This is a test.
I should have told you.
AUDIENCE: Educating
the young ones, maybe?
CAROL SANFORD: Educating
the young ones.
So you have a strong sense
that, like, when they get older,
it's sometimes really hard to
change minds and grow people.
But young.
So I see several people
shaking their head.
Where else do people have
a thought about here's
where I would start, or
here's where I might focus?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: So why?
Say a little more and
what that would look like.
You happen to be in a company
that knows a bit about that,
right?
AUDIENCE: Sure.
CAROL SANFORD: But
where would you take it?
Where would you focus, and why?
AUDIENCE: In addition to the
youngsters that need access
to it, other people who
will get the message
through the [INAUDIBLE] need to
get the third-world countries
that currently can't get to it.
CAROL SANFORD: So we've
got a lot of disparity
in the distribution of
knowledge, understanding,
capability.
And if we could create an
access that leveled that playing
field, that could
make a big difference
not just for one
society at a time,
but more of a grander society.
That makes sense.
One more.
Anybody else have a thought
about where they would start,
where they would leverage from?
AUDIENCE: I would
start from education.
That's kind of a--
CAROL SANFORD: And any
particular part of education
or topic, focus?
AUDIENCE: Yes, just something
like a global [INAUDIBLE]
global view.
And [INAUDIBLE]
across [INAUDIBLE] you
could promote
[INAUDIBLE] diversity
and a multi-cultural
environment, and a global view.
CAROL SANFORD: When you
move around the States,
it becomes very quickly
clear how many people in most
of the US have never
left the United States.
Right?
They've not left it
mentally or physically.
They've rarely read
books about it.
And if they watch it as a
culture story, what they're
watching usually is a
war between two worlds.
So your thought would be coming
to appreciate and understand
could make a big difference.
I got to work with Colgate
Palmolive in South Africa just
the two years before the
elections and the two years
afterwards.
Oh my god.
You cannot imagine
a time like that,
where the turn of
history is happening.
And one of the things that
I thought while I was there
is I wanted to pick up every
black African in the United
States that was
under 16 years old
and have them come watch this
happen-- to see the power,
to see the transition,
to see what could happen.
But I couldn't figure
out how to fund it.
Actually, I should have also
taken all the white kids, now
that I say that.
Because they're the ones that
should have seen the power
that was happening, too.
So I think these are
three great places
to start-- so education,
people, access to knowledge,
and a connection with diversity.
So listen just a
bit as I talk, then,
to these stories from
what you would do.
And even if you didn't
tell us what yours is,
or you're perfectly fine
stealing someone else's idea
if it feels right for you too.
Let's look just a
little bit at why
I think entrepreneurs are
what are necessary to do this.
And for me, the
word "entrepreneur"
has nothing to do necessarily
with going out and starting
a business.
It has to do with a way
of seeing the world,
a way of engaging the world.
And it can happen in parenting.
It can happen in
a not-for-profit.
It can happen in your
own standalone business.
Or it can happen as a leader
using someone else's platform,
like Google.
So I'm going to give you
three ways that I think about
and see entrepreneurs
operating, which
is the foundation,
again, of this book.
This isn't in the
book, but it's a bit
about why I wrote the book.
One of things that I think
is a characteristic that's
core to entrepreneurship,
or thinking of the world
entrepreneurially, is that
the person that's doing that
has a lot of personal agency.
Do you know what I mean by that?
Nothing stops them.
Needs doing?
I'm the one that's in there.
I come up with the ideas
and I move the ideas.
I get knocked down, I
bounce right back up.
There is a strong sense of
internal locus of control.
I'm not a victim.
So that's one of things
I see in entrepreneurs,
is this strength
of personal agency.
The second thing that I
see is that they're always
about making a difference.
They're not very
interested in just doing
kind of better something
somebody else has done.
They actually want
to break the mold.
They want to do something
they could really
matter to as many
people as possible.
I love the 10x that
Larry talks about.
But every possibility we have,
we can make a difference.
And entrepreneurs
think that way.
The third thing
here is something
that people rarely
talk about, but I
think it's really
important, which
is bringing your uniqueness
into it, your unique essence.
So each of you are different
than any other person
in this room or any other
person on the planet.
And I'm not just talking
about physically.
I'm talking about kind of at
a being level-- who you are.
When you were a child,
people would look at you
and they'd say, well,
I think he or she's
going to be a piano player.
I'm looking at my three and
a half-year-old granddaughter
right now.
And she just got her
costume for Halloween.
And she is a knight
in shining armor.
That's what she picked-- three
and a half-year-old girl.
And we have pictures of
her standing with a sword,
and she says, I'm off
to save the world.
So it just makes me wonder--
what is Sylvia going to be?
And each of us had
that version of us.
And then the next time most
of us hear about it-- well,
actually, you won't hear it.
But it would be
your funeral, when
people talk about how
you were, who you are,
why you were different
in the world.
But that's in us all along,
and often it gets lost.
And especially when you're
in a great business,
you can be swept into
other people's work.
And so what I believe
is entrepreneurial
is bringing back who
you are and making sure
that you are embedding
who you are in the work.
There is a new thing called
social entrepreneurs.
You've probably heard or read
about social entrepreneurs--
a whole passel of folks
who find causes and issues
and then they form a
business around them.
And they add one
thing-- they tend
to lose one thing that my base
entrepreneur doesn't have.
But they add this thing
that my grandmother
called external considering.
You might have guessed already
I didn't mind people very well,
and I didn't stay inside the
boundaries that I was given.
And I was in trouble a lot.
And my grandmother's
primary question to me
always was, didn't you consider
anybody else beside yourself?
No.
Not at that age when
she was asking me that.
But as I've grow, I
now know that what
I want to do is
consider-- and when
I wrote the book "The
Responsible Business"
about the stakeholders,
what I was trying to do
is introduce this combination of
external considering, like what
is the life of your
customer or user like.
And how many of you
have read the new
"How Google Works" that's out?
AUDIENCE: Not yet.
CAROL SANFORD: I bought
it the minute I saw it.
I had read it by the time I
landed in Denmark two weeks
ago.
You have to read it.
You'll remember
why you are here.
It's just amazing.
But of course, the message
that is threaded all the way
through it is stand
in the user's shoes.
And that's exactly
how you all think.
I think that's one of
the reasons [? Michel ?]
got so excited about my book,
is that I was giving ways
to go be in the life of the
people that you were serving,
and then connect all
of the co-creators.
And the co-creators
for me are everyone
who serves the customer or user.
And that means the suppliers you
hire, the contractors you hire,
the people who are
called employees,
which is a really
weird word, but all
of those kind of people,
and that they do it in a way
that Earth is served
and made healthier,
and that communities
grow and remain
unique, and the
investors who count on us
for an enduring return
get taken care of.
So all of that to me is
external considering.
And it actually has
to happen in sequence,
but that's in the last
book, and we're actually
not going to talk
about that today.
But if you get interested,
you can go find it.
So that's one of
the first things
the social entrepreneur does.
However, instead of driven
by making a big difference,
they tend to be driven by issues
of where something is broken.
So they find something
that's not working well
or a problem that
needs to be solved.
And so like stoves
in South Africa--
I mean fires,
cutting down trees.
What they'll do is create a
small little stove that people
could use that doesn't pollute,
it doesn't cut down trees.
Of course, it doesn't stop what
caused us having that problem.
So that's why I say
it's like issue-based.
It's not really working
on the whole system,
which you'll see
in the next one.
The other thing that happens
for the social entrepreneur
is they lose their unique
essence expression most
of the time.
And they become dedicated
to something else
they want to change.
The sad part of that is
that then they get burnout.
Because if you're not in
it, you don't get fuel back.
You don't get nurtured back.
So I want us to go
to this third level.
And what this book
was about was creating
what I call "the responsible
entrepreneur," which
is different than
social entrepreneur.
Because their true businesses--
the social entrepreneurs
are often businesses that are
operating like not-for-profits.
You know, they could have
been a not-for-profit,
but they're not
supposed to do that now.
They're supposed
to make a business.
The responsible entrepreneur
is a deep and abiding business
person.
And they are creating a
business because they believe
that there are forms
of capitalism which
can make society work better.
And it's a part of
entrepreneurship.
So they have personal agencies.
You can see all three of these
folks have personal agency.
But there's one thing that I
introduce into businesses--
and it was really easy to
do in South Africa because
of the transition-- which
is something called promises
beyond ableness.
Now, in Google
audiences, you can
guess what that
means very quickly.
Most people say, what?
What do you mean
promises beyond ableness?
It means seeing something
you think could be done,
but you don't know how to do it.
But you're willing to promise
to figure out how to do it
and you're willing
to put it in writing.
You're willing to commit to it.
You're willing to fight
for the resources to do it.
You're willing to have
performance tied against it,
and you're willing to grow
yourself in order to get there.
So I put those
into all companies
that I work with-- everybody.
I don't care whether
you are an engineer
or whether you are person who
is keeping an operation clean.
Whatever your role
is, how is it you
find your promise
beyond ableness?
Because to me,
that's core to you
getting to live your fullest
life and make a big difference.
The external considering
then comes in that form.
But there's one other thing--
besides that the unique essence
expression stays there-- which
is this idea of whole systems
change.
So you know I talked about how
a social entrepreneur works
on an issue.
What the responsible
entrepreneur works on
is the system that
caused the issue.
So they aren't
problem-solvers, they're
game-changers of systems.
So they may change
judicial systems.
One of the things that
the Google Innovation Food
Lab is doing-- Lab
for Food Experience--
is that they are working on
actually changing everyone
on the planet's
relationship to food.
Everyone.
Soil, nutrition, its affect on
climate-- speak of a promise
beyond ableness, right?
It's huge.
But it also is working on
the system in every case--
how it is that we
grow food, how it
is we make choices about food.
And so the movement
of the whole system
is what this
entrepreneur is about.
So this book is full
of 15 stories of people
who go after the whole system,
make promises beyond ableness,
bring their uniqueness
and distinctiveness to it,
and make something
amazing happen.
Doe that sound interesting?
You're going to love
reading these stories.
I'm glad.
I hope you all read the book
in addition to just taking it.
And most people tell me
they're reading all the way
through it, which
is very exciting.
So I want to tell
you a story about how
I came to the term archetypes.
I am 1/16 Mohawk.
I know I don't look like it.
Whatever the bone structure
and stuff that I could have had
didn't get here.
But the stories
from my grandfather
of my great, great,
great grandfather, who
was a part of the Trail of Tears
that went across the Southern
US-- you're all too young.
Do any of you know about
the Trail of Tears?
You know about it.
So it was when they moved
Native Americans, Indians,
off of their natural
living places
and tried to move them--
well, did move them
all in to reservations mostly
in Oklahoma and New Mexico,
a little bit in Texas, but
all of those are gone now.
And 90% of the people
who were moved died.
So it wasn't a real
well-planned, well-executed--
and maybe nobody cared.
But my great, great,
great grandfather
was one of those folks.
And he was responsible, as
the chief of the tribe--
became chief along the way--
of regenerating a tribe
and regenerating a nation.
And what they used
were four archetypes
which are necessary for
anything to be reborn.
And again, you can see
this in any team you're in.
And I've created modern
versions of these,
but here's what the terms
were that my grandfather used.
So the warrior is not
the one who fights.
He said they are the ones who
ask, what's worth fighting for?
And the clown is not the one
who just entertains and is
the stand-up comic, but
they teach us something.
They point out the
elephant in the room.
And they do it with humor so
that we can be uncomfortable
or we can feel it.
We've extracted that out
of most of our things
and put it on a stage--
in an improv theater
or a stand-up comedian.
The hunter is not the person
who just hunts, but makes
sure that everything stays
healthy-- the soil is healthy,
the people are healthy--
for next generations.
And the headman or
headwoman is the one
who asked, how should we
think about this so we could
get better answers
than we got last time?
That's what my
grandfather taught me.
And I've been introducing
that into businesses
all these years, and tried to
bring an understanding that it
is not one of
these that you are,
but you have to use all of them.
So if you were going
to go out and you
wanted to take on a
promise beyond ableness,
you probably will have to
use all four over time.
You'll have to ask,
what's worth fighting for?
Where's the elephant
in the room?
How do we nourish everything?
And how are we
going to think about
so we get a better answer
than we did last time?
And if you don't feel like
you can don that mantle
and play all of
them, then you've
got to go get some friends.
My grandfather,
apparently, rounded up
a bunch of other folks,
and they rebuilt a nation.
And I got to be a
part of that lineage.
You'll notice when you-- if you
do-- go look at the dedication,
it's to my grandfather,
and to my grandson, who
is named after him, and to
my mother, who recorded all
those stories and kept
them and passed them along,
and to Sylvia, the knight
in shining armor, who
is part Maya and part Mexican.
So she has a tribal
heritage too.
So that's what's
behind this book.
I want to differentiate
one thing here, though.
Because archetypes-- there's
too many words on that.
Just let me tell you.
Ignore that.
There's too many words on that.
What I'm trying to
differentiate here
is the difference between an
archetype and your essence.
You are not an
archetype-- never will be.
I do have a quiz.
If you want to, for fun,
you can go to my website
at carolsanford.com.
And you can take it.
And it'll say, here's what
you default to all the time.
You tend to always
be a warrior, or you
tend to always step
into hunter role
and are worried about the
nourishment and keeping
everything going.
But the idea is that you want
to learn to use all of them.
But in every case, you
will do it your way.
Essence is you,
as I said earlier.
You will never be anyone else.
So the archetypes are
like a patterned response.
And the essence is who you,
are and no one can ever
take that away from you-- either
that, that or you're gone.
So the thing that I would
like to share with you,
and then I want to go
back to interacting
with you a little bit.
I want you to think
about the example
that you came up
with that you said
we should work on-- education,
information and access to it,
and understanding and
value in the diversity--
and ask which of these are
arenas-- because they can help
you know which archetype
to use-- which of these
would you have to work on?
Now, maybe all of
them, and I do have
one story in the book of a
woman who worked on all four.
But you will tend to need to
move one of these, maybe two.
So everybody get back
in your mind something
you think you would work
on if you were really
going to improve
society and ecosystems.
What I've found in
working with my clients
and the research that I've done
is that those archetypes now
work on four major
arenas they change.
So the question is going
to be, which of these
would you take on?
The first is
changing an industry.
I have stories in the
book-- and, by the way,
60% of the stories are
women, some women of color,
and 40% are men.
Because I find it
that they're kind
of imbalanced, which
most books get written.
And actually, I use four
icons at the beginning,
of which Larry Page is one.
And it has been the
most reprinted--
more people have
asked to reprint
that story than any other.
Number two is the
Costco story, which
they keep reprinting everywhere.
So you'll enjoy the Larry Page
story, because there are pieces
there that I had to
dig like crazy to get.
And I love that I have actually
Google-approved stories
in this book.
[LAUGH] It's hard to get, right?
So industry is the first one.
And that's what
the warrior does.
They work on
changing industries.
The clown works on
changing social systems.
So what I mean by
a social system
would be something
like-- well, anything
that we as a society structure
to help us work together,
like the tax system.
Anybody think it
could be improved?
Do you have a feeling it might
improve democracy or equality
or any other things if we
worked on the tax system?
Anybody think, yeah.
I think that might.
Well, I have one person--
the story's not in this book.
But we had a
conversation, and I said,
what if the essence of
the IRS was actually
to improve wealth in the nation?
Just everybody
becoming wealthier?
If that were its purpose,
would it be run differently,
and would we have enough taxes?
Would we have enough money?
So I have somebody who is
not far enough along for me
to write their story
yet, but they're really
working on that social
system and redefining,
re-imagining what it's about.
The next one is to be able
to change cultural paradigms.
Now, I think this
was part of-- I
don't know-- what's your name?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: [INAUDIBLE].
I think that what you
were talking about,
how we culturally get locked
into our individual views
of a cultural group
or a cultural paradigm
or a culture way of
working, and then each of us
have our own narrow
little box about that.
The challenge of this
particular archetype
is to actually change
what people believe.
Whew.
And there have been so many
books out recently saying you
cannot change what
people believe.
Well, I know that's not true,
because I actually literally
used to believe that I could
tell someone's race by taking
a blood test, because my
father taught me that.
And it farmed an entire culture
around how I saw the world.
But it is possible
to change belief
by engaging, by information,
by engagement, particularly
with information.
The information
alone didn't do it.
But coming to know people, be
with people, live in a world
where you're more engaged
changed a cultural paradigm
for me.
And I have two stories in the
book about people who are doing
that, one of which is Michael
[? Bacher. ?] [? Michel. ?] I
can't say his name.
Can you say that?
[? MALE SPEAKER: Michel. ?]
[? CAROL SANFORD: Michel. ?]
Right?
Anybody else say that?
Yeah?
Do you all call him that, or
do you just call him Michael?
[? MALE SPEAKER: Michael. ?]
CAROL SANFORD: It's
just easier, right?
But I try to, and then I
mess it up all the time.
But I feel like I had
good intentions, right?
[LAUGH] On the fourth
one here, the paradigm
of the headman or
headwoman is working
on governing agreements.
And again, I have the story
of Google and Larry Page
here as just setting the
tone at the beginning
of the book about how it is
you can go public and actually
improve democracy
and capitalism.
Do you tell that story when
you hire people or interview
people?
It's a phenomenal story about
how you decide to go public.
Only 16 companies had actually
done the Dutch auction
in the US that Google
did before Google did it.
Now that number is about
that number every year,
but people are
still afraid of it.
They don't understand
how it could work.
So what happened
is that you take
an agreement which
we already have.
Larry didn't say, let's change
all the laws and the rules.
He said, let's
use what we've got
and let's make it all change.
The same thing happened
with the broadband,
with the analog, when Google bid
on something in order to-- I'm
told that the reason we
can keep our phone numbers
is because of what
Google did with the SEC.
And that story is in the book.
So you take the
governing agreements
that already exist-- because
it's really hard to change
government, even through voting.
We vote, and we
think, didn't we vote
for different people who
would work on different stuff?
And we don't always get them.
So you have to learn to work
the governing agreement.
So this book has stories of
people who are doing that.
So I gave new names to these.
So instead of warrior, clown,
hunter, headman, I said,
what are they working on?
And it turns out what the
warrior is working on is really
this seeing reality in a
way that we normally don't.
And I've got a couple
of stories there.
But the one story
I want to tell you
is the reconnection
entrepreneur.
Kip Baratoff-- oh.
Kip is quite an
amazing young man.
And he decided that the social
system he wanted to change
was how economic
development happened along
the coast of Oregon,
where he lives.
The fishermen were going out
of business left and right
who were there.
All of the people that
supported them were going out
of business.
They were creating
social systems
to give them money to
try and retrain them.
Let's let you be something
else besides a fisherman.
Let's let you be something else
besides a company that cans.
Let's just move all of you
out of that and change it.
And he said, but that
is a way to live.
And on the coast,
it's really important.
He created a cooperative.
It's not a legal cooperative.
Be but he brought together the
boat, the captain that fishes,
the fisher people who are
on the boat-- in fact,
the company's called Fish
People-- the people who can
and process, those
who distribute,
and those who sell
it, like Costco,
into an ongoing group that
meets together every other week
to look at the whole system.
When you go to Costco,
you can actually
learn what they're doing with
any specific piece of fish.
Any of you shop at Costco ever?
So take your phone.
It will look for Fish
People's package.
You will see a QR code on it.
It will you who the captain of
the boat was that caught that.
It'll tell you who it
was that canned it.
It'll tell you how
it was processed.
It will even tell you what the
mercury and any other metals
content is in that piece of
fish you're about to buy.
It has creating chaos in
Costco, because everybody
wants to know why is nobody else
doing what's happening here?
And it's rebuilding the
entire economic development
structure around the
fishing industry,
rather than trying to solve the
problem, which was retraining
them, giving them money
to get them through.
And they're figuring out how
to do sustainable fishing.
I don't think we have
Google buying from them yet,
but it just occurred to me,
we should talk about them.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
MALE SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: Yeah.
And I actually was thinking
when we were in Austin
that I was going to have
Michael talking to him,
and that didn't work.
So you and I will have
that conversation.
So isn't that an
interesting story?
Now, this guy got
this idea while he
was living in a yurt in the
middle of winter in Yellowstone
for nine months
to figure out what
he wanted to do with his life.
Because he had been a Goldman
Sachs, very successful,
analyst.
And he said, I don't
have enough meaning.
I still need to make money, but
I need to make meaning also.
And he said, I think
I'm going to go find out
how to do economic development.
There's a long story
between it, and I
tell you a little bit
of it in the book.
But that's the kind of stories
I'm talking about in this book.
And then Michael, he
was sitting in Starwood
before he came here.
And the stories
that I was really
touched by when I met
Michael were how much
he saw intelligence in
things that most people saw
as a problem.
You may know this story.
When he was in Starwood,
many of the people
were coming up from
the Middle East.
And he also had responsibility
for the Middle East
and Europe for Starwood
Resorts for food.
Many of those people who
were coming up obviously
did not speak the language
in the European Union
very well, wherever they were.
Other people thought
they were stupid.
Michael said, no, no.
Language has nothing
to do-- you know,
speaking another language has
nothing do with intelligence.
Give people work to do.
Find ways to put translators.
And he rebuilt the entire
service system for Starwood
based on using
language as a leverage
and giving people the ability
to learn the language.
So he actually started thinking
about that kind of global ship
before he got here.
He's an amazing human being,
and there's more of his stories
and even of his
childhood in this book.
So what I would like to do
is ask a few of you who had--
and maybe the same
three who volunteered,
if you're willing--
to ask which industry
or which arena do you think
you might want to affect if you
were going to work
on the diversity.
Because if you
change an industry,
you have to go work on
getting the best product.
Everybody sees you out
in front as the lead.
And then you have to
use that platform.
And if it's a social
system, you've
got to figure out how to
intervene, like Kip did,
in a way that goes and
works on a system, not just
a piece of something.
And the education system is
deeply in need of somebody
figuring out how to intervene
in the education system.
How would you, Brian, intervene?
Do you know how you'd
intervene for the access?
I'm going to go back so you
can see what those [INAUDIBLE].
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE] similar
to your thoughts [INAUDIBLE]
story where I had a meeting with
manufacturers maybe five or six
years ago, and asked them if
they saw a pipeline directly
into factories, particularly
in China, where they could see
what was being manufactured,
and at least [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: Wow.
Yeah.
AUDIENCE: They laughed
at me, because we're not
anywhere close to
that point, but it
sounds like a [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: Well,
other persons are.
Industries are not.
But, you know, I think
there is an opportunity.
I don't know how
you'd play it out,
but I love that you can see.
You can actually help shift
an industry just by talking--
and I think Google
does that, generally.
So that's very good.
Do you have any
thoughts about how
you'd intervene in
the education system
to work with young people?
What would you do?
How would you up-end
that industry?
Because it is an
industry, right?
It's like producing widgets.
Get the kids out.
Give them a test.
No Child Left Behind, but
all of them are left behind.
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: Yeah.
Do you think about it
off and on, though?
When I ask you
what would you work
on, that was one of the
thoughts you had, right?
Does anybody else think
about how would you
work on education?
Anybody know?
Where would you intervene?
If you were going to be a
responsible entrepreneur
and you were going to
intervene and save us
from what we're
doing with education.
AUDIENCE: Jamie
Oliver is probably
a good example [INAUDIBLE].
Impacting the school
systems and trying
to take that route to
make inroads, which
seems from the
outside looking in,
the easiest way to
do it, [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: And
what do you think
is the essence of
what Jamie's doing?
What is it that makes-- because
he is being very powerful,
along with Louis, helping
him make that happen.
What is he doing--
AUDIENCE: He's
disrupting everything.
CAROL SANFORD: He's
disrupting-- yeah.
He's making things also
very concrete and practical,
isn't he?
So kids learn while cooking--
and adults, families, learn.
So I think there is a
piece of information
tied to practice that he does.
So that would stay
with what you're doing.
What else do you see?
How would you work?
What would you
work on if you were
working on improving diversity?
Because we're doing a terrible
job of that in the US overall.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
[INAUDIBLE] program
and [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: For all
schools, all children.
AUDIENCE: Yeah.
And even with technology
and [INAUDIBLE],
we can use this virtual system,
with the internet [INAUDIBLE].
I'm thinking like
an example, here.
Like the US and China or India.
You don't need to be in
the same physical location.
[INAUDIBLE] system [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: So the
exposure and the connection,
where people begin to feel
real, is one of the ways
we can move that.
That's how that cultural
paradigm's going to move.
I did something very
interesting in South Africa.
Because one of the
constitutional mandates
was that the leadership of
the business, top management,
had to reflect the population,
which was 97% black Africans.
And guess what the top
management of Colgate
looked like when we got there?
Of course it was
97% white Africans.
But what we said to them is,
no one is going to lose a job.
What we want to do is be able
to have you become resources,
and we want to be able to meet
that mandate in six months.
We only lost one person
who didn't want to play,
because Staleo Sasos,
the leader of it,
said I want to build a
great country while we
build a great company.
We did one other thing,
which is we looked
to ask each person about
their essence, what
they were attracted
to working on.
And instead of trying to do
diversity programs-- because
we had eight tribes in here.
And believe it or not,
there was this much warring
between eight black African
tribes as there was here.
But having each
person look at essence
got us, instead of looking at
classes or races of people,
looking at each person uniquely.
So we're running out of time.
I am going to ask if you have
anything you want to ask me.
I've been asking you
questions, and I'm
willing to answer one or
two, if you have something
you think I could help you with.
And by the way, I'm happy
to talk beyond this.
If you guys take on these
things you just talked about,
I would love to talk with
you to support you doing it.
Is there anything
people want to ask me?
MALE SPEAKER: Obviously
after some of the work
you've been doing with
the food [INAUDIBLE],
I think there's so much
great stuff to share.
And it's tough to do
within the 45-minute slot.
But what's been some of
the most exciting things
that you had the
opportunity to partner
with Michael to [INAUDIBLE] some
of the game changing things?
And I think it goes back
to the Innovation Lab.
So what are some of the exciting
projects that you [INAUDIBLE]?
CAROL SANFORD: Well, of
course the one I'm closest to
is the community
of practice that's
related to ecosystems, with
Pie Ranch and the other ranches
which are becoming involved.
But what I really love about
that is the mix of views.
So we have people who are
looking at farm to table-- farm
to family, I guess it is.
We have people who are
looking at farm to table,
which is insight into Google.
But the fun part is many of
those groups have now created--
it's fun for me,
I think it's fun
for them-- have created
a person in a role,
like bon appetit, who
is calling himself
the responsible
business coordinator.
So they're making
sure that people
are asking the questions,
do we keep the user in mind?
Are we really paying
attention to keeping everybody
who works here connected
to it, and feeling
like their own uniqueness
can be brought to it?
And some of you, I'm sure,
are being affected by that.
Obviously Google is
so paying attention
to regenerate the Earth.
And, by the way, sustainability
isn't even close enough for me.
If you read my other book,
I trash sustainability.
Sorry.
Because it's all
about doing less bad,
and it's not really about-- I
mean, Earth has an agreement.
And she would love for us,
every time we took resources,
to improve her
health and vitality,
not just do a little less harm.
And we, of course, have Google
Maps who are involved in that.
So we're actually
able to begin to see
how that's influencing
where we are.
We went to Stockholm
and connected
with people from
all over the world
to show them what
Google was doing--
information being spread.
We had people from Asia as
well as all over Africa--
I don't think we had any
South Americans there.
Watching that is very exciting.
I do also enjoy the
people who are looking
at the eating environment
and how that influences
the choices we made, and how
do we improve people's choice.
So I know there's so many good
things going on in that lab.
And I don't know whether that's
how all innovation labs turn
out for Google, but
that one, I think,
is going to make a profound
difference-- a really
profound difference.
Anything I should add to that?
I'm so immersed in it
now, I've kind of--
AUDIENCE: No.
I was just trying to get
your perspective on it,
because the lab's
only been happening
for a few years [INAUDIBLE].
It's getting some great
momentum behind it.
CAROL SANFORD: Are
you hearing about it?
Are you hearing about the
lab, the innovation lab?
No?
AUDIENCE: [INAUDIBLE].
CAROL SANFORD: OK.
Well, there's a little bit
about it in the new book,
so you can read some of that.
And I think we're ramping
up some more stories.
All right.
So I feel like I should
say thank you to all of you
for coming.
I think you will
love this book, not
just because I wrote it--
because you should know the way
I write books is
that I dictate them,
and I have brilliant
people who then
make it shorter sentences
and all that kind of stuff.
But the people in
this book are amazing,
including [? Michael ?]
[? Bacher ?].
So thank you all for coming.
And if you'd like for me to
sign your book, please stay
and I'm happy to do that for
another 15 minutes or so.
MALE SPEAKER: Thank you, Carol.
CAROL SANFORD: Thank you.
AUDIENCE: Thank you.